why did you make me do that look at me  focus on my voice I'm not giving up on  you Jean she was my friend you're my  family James no matter what  look  you're special gene and if you stop  fighting that force inside here  you embrace it  he will possess the very power of a God  she'll kill us all tell me how we fix  this trough tell me what to do I don't  know what to do  no they don't understand they fear and  what they fear we seek to destroy  it's your fault Charles I try to protect  our I'm scared  when I lose control bad things happen to  people i watch the girl dies she's still  June we can still help her sometimes you  want to believe people as something that  they are not  by the time you realize who they are  it's too late  she's coming  [Music]  you  you